So first we want to do
is basically compute H,
but loop until we get
the most popular H.
How to we start?
Well, select four feature
points at random.
Compute the homography
between all of them, exactly.
But then start looking for
the sum of squared differences
between the inlier for the new one.
And, basically, the one that's computed,
with respect to some threshold.
Keep the largest set of inliers.
And then re-compute the H estimate
within all of the inliers.
And the basic idea here is that there
are more inliers than outliers.
Well, that doesn't really help.
The idea really is,
is which outliers are wrong from a set
that is actually much more correct.
So, giving more consensus or
more power, more popularity to the ones
that actually are matching each other
is what the key is, not that there
are a number of samples more.
But there could be a lot of samples, but
it's going to go choose the one that are
actually more similar to each other and
that'll be the one that
we want to look for.